gersón en el sur de Ucrania una ciudad
constantemente bombardeada por el
ejército ruso estacionado ahora en
frente
el pasado mes de octubre los rusos
evacuaron a la población civil antes de
retirarse ante la contraofensiva del
ejército ucraniano esta mujer Es testigo
de la evacuación del orfanato situado
frente a su casa había tres autobuses
grandes y blancos estacionados delante
de la puerta durante de la entrada había
un coche blindado acordonaron toda la
zona estaban armados y no dejaban que
nadie se acercara incluso vinieron a
revisar los teléfonos móviles para que
no los grabáramos todos los habitantes
estaban conmocionados pero no podíamos
hacer nada secuestraron a estos niños y
los deportaron 48 niños de 0 a 5 años el
21 de octubre el hombre que fue nombrado
alcalde de gersón por los rusos
describió su deportación como una
operación de rescate
hemos salvado a estos niños están a
salvo el director del orfanato está con
ellos todo el tiempo todo saldrá bien
créanme Nuestro objetivo es salvar vidas
y pensar en el futuro de nuestros niños
en realidad la directora y representante
legal de los niños fue despedida por los
rusos a cambio de una empleada que
estaba bajo órdenes pudimos contactarla
por teléfono
por supuesto porque me negué a cooperar
me ofrecieron varias veces trabajar para
ellos pero me negué comprendieron que
obstruiría sus acciones Así que Me
despidieron
encontramos a estos niños en esta foto
con el responsable oficial de derechos
de la infancia de Vladimir Putin
desde la invasión a gran escala en
Ucrania María el boba belova realiza
videos de propaganda
huérfanos que traslada de los
territorios ocupados en Ucrania acogidos
con gran entusiasmo por sus nuevas
familias rusas
en la ciudad todos los hospitales son
bombardeados Aquí está el primer impacto
de proyectil en esta ventana y unas
ventanas más allá ha caído otro misil
en este hospital infantil de gersón los
médicos trabajan siempre con riesgo
permanente
aquí cayó otro proyectil
entró por la ventana y atravesó Esta
pared
esto también ocurrió en nochevieja
recibimos siete misiles nuestro hospital
fue bombardeado tres veces
seguimos trabajando porque solo quedamos
nosotros
durante la ocupación estos médicos
corrían otro riesgo
Esta es nuestra unidad de cuidados
intensivos aquí teníamos nuestro
laboratorio en su pabellón ahora
inhabilitado escondieron a diez
huérfanos de los rusos aquí habíamos
instalado camas y calefacción en el
cubículo de allí les preparábamos la
comida lo sabíamos atrincherado había
cerrado las puertas para impedir el
acceso por el Pacífico
Olga cuenta que cada mañana tras el
anuncio de la evacuación el mando ruso
exigía listas de los niños que podían
ser evacuados del hospital los médicos
preparaban documentos falsos y colocaban
respiradores junto a las camas para
fingir que los pequeños pacientes no
podían salir
Por supuesto que teníamos miedo era un
riesgo muy grande para todo el personal
y para todo el hospital pero cada uno
desde su posición defiende a Ucrania
esta era nuestra forma de defenderla una
nación normal no llega con tanques y
para toda nación lo más importante son
los niños así que por supuesto todo el
mundo debe hacer todo lo posible por
defenderlos
en gerson el director de este internado
para huérfanos y niños bajo tutela
también escondió a sus hijos con
familias y con sus empleados durante la
operación
Esta es nuestra sala de fiestas donde
organizamos actos conciertos y
celebramos el año nuevo y aquí están las
fotos de nuestros 52 niños que pudimos
esconder durante la ocupación
la guerra en Ucrania dura ya ocho años y
hemos visto lo que pasaba endoniaks
Cómo se llevaban a los niños de allí
También conocemos la historia de la
Unión soviética de la deportación de los
tártaros de crimea y de los de
ucranianos de Ucrania occidental a
Siberia o creemos o creencia por eso
sabíamos que también podríamos sufrir
ese destino
a principios del verano los rusos
llegaron a la casa de bolodimir por
primera vez
del fcb y soldados la primera pregunta
que me hicieron fue Dónde están los
niños siempre preguntaban dónde estaban
los niños vinos Dónde están los niños
poco más de un mes después los rusos le
llevaron a acoger a otros 15 huérfanos y
a su directora que habían sido evacuados
de un refugio en el frente
Aquí están los niños
nos los trajeron en vehículos militares
los niños estaban muy asustados pensaban
que se los llevaban a Rusia vivieron con
nosotros tres meses
luego el 19 de octubre cuando los rusos
se retiraron de gerson se llevaron a los
niños con ellos no tuvimos elección les
dije por favor déjenlos Hasta mañana
tienen que prepararse no son soldados
son solo niños dijeron les damos dos
horas si se resisten vendremos con más
soldados para llevarnoslos
con ayuda de ongs Internacionales estos
niños pudieron ser finalmente evacuados
de Rusia Ucrania afirma que 307 niños
fueron devueltos de los más de 16.200
deportados en la opacidad de la guerra
es imposible por el momento evaluar
Cuántos fueron devueltos con el
consentimiento de sus padres y
representantes legales o secuestrados
como los niños de gerson